avec tout le monde debout franck dubosc
passe à la réalisation est évidemment le
pitch et à dormir debout
duboscq campe un dragueur invétéré qui
se fait passer pour un handicapé afin de
séduire une jeune femme en fauteuil joué
par alexandra lamy
j'ai rencontré le duo festival de
comédie de l'alpe d'huez où le film
était présenté hors compétition puisque
son président n'était autre que franck
dubosc et je vous rassure tout le monde
était très bien assis pour l'interview
[Musique]
alexandra lamy franck dubosc bonjour
merci d'être avec nous on est à l'alpe
d'huez francs que vous êtes président du
jury vous avez présenté hier votre film
hors compétition tout le monde de vous
que nous avons tous adoré donc merci
d'être là ça devrait s'arrêter là mais
bon j'avais alors s'arrêtant sur une
note positive comme ça maintenant on
était super heureux parce qu'évidemment
hier on avait le trac c'est la première
fois qu'on présentait le film avec du
public et on a été d'ailleurs que tu m'a
dit qu'il y avait le vieux de huit ans
qui a été obligé de monter le son de la
whey j'avais le texte le break aux sons
qu'ils étaient costauds que tu es obligé
de monter le son très très fort parce
qu'on n'entend plus le savez quoi je me
hockey est morte effectué ma main je
pense qu'il aurait muté allumant une
dernière fois chez votre nouvelle
voisine de palier je suis auxiliaire de
j je m'occupe de gens comme vous jouerez
mois
oui mais parfois barbe de jeu dimanche
face à la relève je marche mais voilà
c'est jocelyn le prestigieux qu'est ce
qu'on raconte
et moi j'ai la grandeur voilà voilà
florence lasserre célibataire vous devez
avoir un mille trucs à vous dire entre
entre parisien quelle a été votre
réaction quand quand franck vous a
proposé ce rôle
alors d'abord j'étais extrêmement
touchée que franck eux viennent de
proposer le rôle parce que on se
connaissait un petit peu mais pas
énormément et qui viennent me chercher
j'ai été extrêmement flatté jo du doigt
et puis j'ai lu le scénario j'ai trouvé
ça extrêmement audacieux c'était son
premier film et je me suis dit je trouve
toujours un peu intéressant aussi les
acteurs qui passe à la réalisation parce
que comme france
il raconte une histoire ils sont
toujours sur l'histoire et avec les
personnages c'est c'est pas la technique
qui prend le dessus sur le sur le film
alors l attitude à sion alors la petite
cuba si franck pourquoi maintenant pour
réaliser votre premier long métrage
et pourquoi cette histoire tout le monde
me demande c'est difficile parce que
c'est plein de c'est la conjonction de
plein de trucs en fait du mensonge du
handicap parce que je j'ai ma maman qui
est dans une chaise maintenant mais même
d'autres personnes et puis le l'amour
moi j'aimais aussi les histoires d'amour
j'aime la comédie j'aime les histoires
d'amour encore à dire oui et puis et
puis me dire je voudrais voir comment
commence à fait on sur le trottoir de
personnes dans les films comédie
romantique images toujours à new york
dans la main avant de se faire un bisou
et puis de monter dans le truc de
syllabes deux chaises comment ils font
pour s'embrasser déjà et je suis à plat
le ressort comique et l'émotion m les
deux en même temps parce que d'abord si
si c'est pas une comédie je me serai pas
autorisée à réaliser parce que le il ya
des gens qui m'aiment bien
est ce cela il faut que je leur donne ce
qu'ils aiment bien de moi c'est pas
c'est pas le franc que triste qu'ils
aiment c'est celui qui les fait rire
qu' il faut que je donne ça aussi et
puis moi jamais dessus la haie alexandra
juste un mot quand même sur votre
prestation parce que vous jouez donc
donc en fauteuil tout le film comment
vous avez abordé ce rôle comment vous
êtes préparé j'ai travaillé évidemment
trois mois en amont avec un je vais
demander la production d'avoir un
fauteuil pour d'abord chez moi qui est
impossible en fait donc ça a été un
enfer beaucoup mais oui mais en même
temps on se rend compte de plein de
difficultés et de encore un petit peu en
retard là dessus et puis le handisport
tennis que j'ai travaillé énormément
avec emmanuel d'ailleurs qu'on voit dans
le film qui surviennent de france qui a
fait les jo etc qui m'a dit voilà et
puis j'ai travaillé oui pendant web bien
trois mois c'est rien mois les commandes
elle est intéressante elle est belle il
ya quelque chose
[Musique]
je suis un florence vous êtes assis sur
ma chaise
alors tout le monde debout c'est un film
sur le mensonge principalement à quoi
bon quand on est acteur et ce qu'on
considère qu'on est un peu menteur je
suis monteur mouais honnêtement non je
me suis je adam plus tellement dans la
vie j'étais un peu mytho quand j'étais à
vie mais je me connais moi-même quoi je
m'inventais des histoires je vais
inventer des vies j'avais raconté à tous
mes copains que j'avais le même chien
que dans belle et sébastien et j'avais
pris en photo alors elle avait pas
laissé le fini rien mais avec un
appareil photo j'avais pris le télé 7
jours en photo et je veux montrer aux
copains mais quand tu es petit tu y
crois donc les copains envoyer une photo
prise d'une autre photo très mal avec le
flash tu sais qui rebondit sur la neige
la tv sur papier glacé vers nulle et
avec un petit peu d'écriture son côté du
melville ou ton chien parce que de la
neige sur la photo jpeg et à la montagne
chez mon grand père et mon grand-père à
la montagne je vais inventer des trucs
ouais enfin bon moi c'est vraiment parce
que non très très mal j'ai en fait le
problème il ya c'est que j'augmente très
rarement parce que je ne me souviens
plus de ce que j'ai dis donc je m'en
prends les pieds et serments faire donc
je me dis que parfois voilà c'est mieux
de dire des choses que je ne manquerai
pas prêt quand on parle de mensonge il
ya aussi
voilà une façon de leur dire ans son
cadet des petits motifs a vraiment des
mensonges c'est aussi de la délicatesse
dont on parle pas de votre tenue
non merci à tous les mercis à un petit
show face à la caméra